[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي الكرام واهلا بكم مره
اخرى بعد
الاجازه هذا وطنا يا ولد لا تقولوا بركان
خمد دم النشامه ما برد
شاعر انتفاضه السويداء ماجد رضوان مخاطبا
النظام السوري الذي باع الوطن واستجلب كل
انواع الغزات والمحتلين والميليشيات كي
يساعدوه في سحق الشعب السوري وحمايه عرشه
الذليل هل انتصر فعلا ام ان ثوار السويداء
اليوم يزلزلون الارض تحت اقدام العصابه
الحاكمه الم يعد اشبال جبل العرب الاشم
الثوره السوريه الى عهدها الاول بمزيد من
الحماسه والعنفوان
الم تذهب كل احلام النظام بالانتصار على
سوريا وشعبها تحت اقدام احفاد سلطان باشا
الاطرش واحمد الهجري وقسام
الحناوي الم يطهر المنتفضون السويداء
وضواحيها من كل رموز النظام وتماثيله
وداسوا
عليها الم تتطهر حافظه من رجس حزب البعث
البائد الم يصبح ابو مرهف وشركاه نكته
العصر الم تعد انتفاضه الجنوب الروح الى
الثوره السوريه الا تبعث الامل في نفوس
السوريين
جميعا الا يرفع نشام ساحه الكرامه كل
شعارات الثوره التي ظن النظام انه سحقها
بالطائرات الروسيه والميليشيات الطائفيه
الا يزيد عدد المسؤولين الدولي
الذين تواصلوا مع سماحه الشيخ ابي سلمان
حكمه الهجري خلال اسبوعين فقط عدد الذين
تواصلوا مع بشار على مدى 12
عاما الا ترنو اعين السوريين اليوم من
الشمال الى الجنوب الى ابو سلمان الذي
اصبح رمزا وطنيا من الطراز الاول لكل
السوريين لكن في المقابل ماذا يمكن ان
تحقق الانتفاضات الجديده اكثر مما حققته
سابقاتها هل يمكن التعويل عليها اذا بقيت
محصوره في جنوب البلاد الا يصمت السوريون
في معظم انحاء سوريا رغم الوضع المعيشي
الكارثي الا يعني ذلك ان السوريين باتوا
يقبلون بواقع الحال اليس هناك توجه دولي
للحفاظ على النظام الا يسير قطار التطبيع
بخطا ثابته مع الاسد رغم كل العقبات ثم هل
قرار التغيير بيد الشعب السوري او النظام
او المعارضه
اصلا الم تخرج القضيه السوريه من ايدي
السوريين اليس قرار الحل بيد القوى الكبرا
حصرا اسئله اطرحها من امريكا على ابن جبل
العرب ماهر شرف الدين وعلى محمود الافندي
الامين العام لحركه الدبلوماسيه الشعبيه
السوريه نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتج المعاكس لو بدات معك
ماهر شرف الدين من
امريكا البعض يقول انه دهاء التاريخ من
كان يتوقع ان يهب المارد في جبل العرب
بهذه الطريقه بعد ان ظن الكثيرون ان
النظام السوري انتصر على سوريا والسوريين
وسحق ثورتهم فاذ به يعني يفاجا الان بان
الجنوب السوري عن بكره ابيه يهب في وجهه
يحطم تماثيله وصوره وكل الرموز من حزب
البعث الى غيره ما الذي حصل ماهر شرف
الدين لقد اثبتت التجربه السوريه بان
ثورات الشعوب هي عباره عن موجات متلاحقه
يعني عندما تنتهي الموجه الاولى ويظن
الطاغيه بان الثوره قد انتهت سرعان ما
تفاجئه الموجه الثانيه كما ح حصل في ثوره
السويداء وطبعا حديثي هنا عن الموجه
الثوريه يختلف قليلا عن المصطلح الشهير
للموجه الثوريه الذي نظر له العديد من
المؤرخين والفلاسفه في الغرب المهم بعدما
ظن بشار الاسد بان الثوره السوريه صارت في
نهايتها جاء حراك السويداء ليثبت للعالم
بان ثوره السوريين لا يمكن ان تنتهي الا
بزوال هذا النظام ما يحدث في السويداء
اليوم هو الموجه الثانيه من الثوره
السوريه والتي نامل ان تكون الموجه
القاضيه حراك السويداء جرد النظام من اهم
ورقه كان يستعملها من اجل البقاء ورقه
حمايه الاقليات يعني السويداء كمعقم
الموحدين الدروز نزعت هذه الورقه المهمه
والمصيري من يد النظام السويداء اثبتت
للعالم بان هذا النظام لا يحمي اقليات بل
يحتمي بها انه ليس نظام حمايه الاقليات بل
هو نظام الاحتماء بالاقليات السويداء نزعت
هذه الورقه المهمه من يد النظام لذلك هو
مرتبك لا يعرف كيف يتعامل مع هذا الحراك
المتصاعد هو لا يستطيع اتهام المتظاهرين
بالارهاب بالسويد لا يوجد اسلام سياسي لا
يوجد اخوان مسلمون لا يوجد جبهه النصره
لذلك يعزف ابواق النظام على نغمه الانفصال
انه هؤلاء انفصاليون وهذه النغمه طبعا
مردوده عليهم لان سلطان الاطرش قائد
الثوره السوريه الكبرى س هو الذي قام
باعاده توحيد سوريا ونحن نعم ونحن احفاد
سلطان ماضون على نهجه طيب تخيل تخيل يا
دكتور منذ الايام الاولى للحراك في
السويداء بدا ابواق النظام بتخويف الناس
من هجوم جديد لداعش وقبل يومين قناه
الميادين ومن دون اي مناسبه تذكر بثت
فيديوهات حصريه عن هجوم الدواعش على
السويداء سنه 2018 طيب ليش لتبث الميادين
هذه الاشرطه اليوم ومن وين جابت هذه
الاشرطه هل مدير الميادين السيد غسم بن
جدو وجد هذه الاشرطه على الشجره كما قال
سنه 2005 عند اغتيال الحريري قال بانه وجد
شريط ابو عدس على الشجره هل وجد ايضا شريط
الدواعش على الشجره يعني يا ريت يدلني على
هالشجرة
السوري لن يستكين قبل تحقيق مطالبه بزوال
الطغمه الحاكمه بزوال الذين يتاجرون
بالكبت جون ويتاجرون بالاقليات ويتاجرون
بفلسطين ويتاجرون بثروات البلاد ومستقبل
البلاد محمود الافندي كيف
ترد اول شيء سعد اوقاتك دكتور فيصل الاخوه
المشاهدين والاستاذ ماهر طبعا من امريكا
طبعا انا هون اختلف مع الاستاذ ماهر عندما
قال فوج النظام لا النظام لم يفاجا بل
سابق هذه الاحتجاجات لذلك حتى الان لم
يتدخل نعود الايادي التي نظمت الاحتجاج في
السويداء اختارت الوقت المناسب نجحت يعني
نعلم جيدا الوقت كان لما رفع النظام
ال الدعم عن المحروقات ادى الى ارتفاع
الاسعار لعده مرات استغل هذا الموقف بعض
الاشخاص وبداوا يشعرون ما يسمى انتفاضه
بالسويداء ولكن نجحوا فقط في اليومين في
اليوم يومين الاوليين بعد يومين من
استمرار الاحتجاجات ما حصل الشعارات التي
اطلقها اخطا فيها اول الشيء وبالاضافه الى
المطالب الشعارات اخذوا شعارات 2011 الشعب
دود اسقاط النظام وهذه الشعارات اصبحت غير
مقبوله لا داخل سوريا ولا خارج سوريا في
الدول الداعمه اذا تريد الدول ان تدعم هذا
الحراك بالنسبه للمطالب المطالب انفصاليه
يعني المطالب التي تطالبها فعليا الاشخاص
اللي نظموا هذا الاحتجاج
المطالب نفس المطالب سبحان الله توافق
مطالب الشيخ مفق طريف هو وصالح طريف عندما
اتوا الى موسكو من اسرائيل الى موسكو
وطالبوا بغدان بنفس المطالب ه
انطقه محمود الافندي محمود الافندي كي كي
يعني كي لا ناكل بعقل الناس حلاوه انتم
انت وكل ابواق النظام اخر من يحق دقيقه
اخر من يحق لكم ان تتحدثوا عن الانفصال
هذا النظام باع سوريا بالجمله والمفرق
الشرق السوري باعه للاكراد ولامر وهو
يتاجر معهم بالنفط باع انت تعلم ماذا باع
للص لروسيا وماذا باع لايران البلد بيع
كله وذهب قبل ايام ليبيع ما تبقى الى
الصين من الذي دق الاسافين في كل عائله
سوريه من الذي فصل كل قريه سوريه من الذي
فصل المدن السوريه من الذي يتاجر
بالشعارات القوميه على مدى 50 عاما و هو
يحكم بطريقه طائفيه من الذي يدمر سوريا من
الذي قسم سوريا لا تتحدث عن انفصال ثواني
ثوان ثواني ثواني لا انا احكيلك اول شيء
يعني لماذا الشعارات الشعارات قبل انه غير
مقبوله ثاني شيء شعب السويدا هو شع
بامتياز شعار
واح دقيقه بس دقيقه انا ماط خليه كمل خليه
كمل خليه كمل بس شعات الانفصال وين شعارات
الانفصال خليني اخي اكمل الفكره اكمل
الفكره يا اخي كمل لما الشعب السويده لما
شعب السويده راى الاعلام الدرزيه ولا هناك
اي عالم اخر غير اعلام الدرزيه بدات
الانخفاض يعني بدات اول شيء الاحتجاجات
ينزل الرقم شيئا فشيئا لوصلنا انهم بداوا
يحشدوا يوم الاثنين والجمعه اليوم يحشدوا
يوم الجمعه فقط يعني احتجاجات يوم الجمعه
الماضي نرى ان اصبحت ساحه للدبكه يعني ما
يعني ساحه للدبكه بس فقط ل ان هناك مساحات
فاضيه في ساحه الكرامه يعني شعب السويدا
لم يصدق بسبب الشعارات اول شيء شعار علم
او رفع علم الدروس فقط في ساحه الكرامه
هذا اهم شيء ثاني شيء المطالب المطالبه
اللي طلبوا فيها محافظه السويداء هناك كان
وفد من حراك السويداء ذهب لمحافظه
السويداء وطالبوا بهذه المطالب التي قلتها
قبل قليل بس مطالب
الشيخ م محمود وصلت الفكره بس محود محمب
محمود محمود قبل ان اذهب الى ماهر قبل ان
اذهب الى ماهر هناك نقاط تاريخيه يجب ان
تمر يجب ان لا ناكل بعقل الناس حلاوه انت
تعلم محمود الافندي جبل العرب
تاريخيا موحد دينيا وموحد وطنيا ودير بالك
لولا الثوره السوريه الكبرى بقياده
السلطان باشا الاطرش لا ما كان هناك سوريا
انت تعلم كان هناك دوله درزيه من
1921 الى
1936 كان هناك دوله درزيه من الذي قضى على
الدوله الدرزيه وصنع سوريا الحديثه اهل
جبل العرب الاشم
ثانيا الاقليات بس خليني اكمل لك الاقليات
الاقليات في اي منطقه تصل اليها الاقليات
او اي جبل تصل اليه الاقليات يسمونه
باسمهم باسمهم لم يسموا الجبل جبل للدروس
سموه جبل العرب وهذا دليل على انهم نزعتهم
وطنيه دائما كيف ترد خليني نروح لعن
ماهر
انا انا قلت هذا الكلام وهذا الكلام قلت
لك انه الوطن اهم شيء بال اهم من من
الطائفيه ولكن بعض الاشخاص يعني اذا قلنا
الان نحن على سبيل المثال ساحه الكرامه
طولها 500 متر عرضها 13 متر 650 متر يعني
الماكسيمم بسع فيها 2000 شخص هذول فقط
الموجودين شعب السويده لم ينجر ورا هذه
الاحتجاجات ليس هناك عصيان مدني
الاحتجاجات عصيان مدني العالم كلها تروح
على وظائفها الكل تشتغل يعني فقط
اختصرت المظاهرات على يوم الجمعه لحشد
العالم ولكن لم تنجح الحشد يعني ليس هناك
احتجاجات في السويداء الان هناك بعض
الاشخاص المخربين موجودين
هناك اذا رايت الشعب
السوؤ شعب السوي لا يؤيد هذا الحرا جدا
ماهر شرف الدين ماهر شرف الدين ليس هناك
انتفاضه انت تهول الامور وليس هناك حشد
وليس هناك ثوره ولا من من يحزنون هناك
يعني كلياتهم شويه ناس صيحوا الى ما هنالك
من هذا الكلام كيف ترد عليه بالله رح ارجع
على تهمه الاعداد والحشد بس قبل بدي ارد
على تهمه الانفصال يعني لانهم لا يقدرون
على اتهامنا بالارهاب في السويداء
يتهمونهم بالانفصال في خزانه النظام هناك
درج خاص في درج يحتوي هذا الدرج على ملف
اتهام لكل طائفه يعني السنه ارهابيون
الدروز انفصاليون وهكذا كل طائفه لها تهمه
جاهزه لها ثوب جاهز يلبسونها اياه بس
تتحرك ضدهم السويده كانت في عشرينيات
القرن الماضي منطلقا كما قلنا لاعاده
تحرير سوريا لاعاده توحيد سوريا وليس عبثا
ان تم تسليم قياده الثوره السوريه الكبرى
لسلطان الاطرش السويداء تاريخيا كانت
الموحده لسوريا بينما جد بشار الاسد كان
في ذلك الوقت يوقع على رساله الذل الشهيره
التي يرجو فيها فرنسا ان تبقى في سوريا
يعني تخيل تخيل ان من يتهمنا بال بالعماله
للخارج هم الذين باعوا ثروات البلاد
للمستعمرين هم الذين باعوا المرافئ
والمطارات هم الذين باعوا النفط والفوسفات
هم الذين باعوا حتى مزارع البقر باعوها
حتى الاراضي الزراعيه باعوها لايران هؤلاء
العملاء والوكلاء للمستعمرين يتهموننا
للعماله تخيل ان من يتهمنا برفع الاعلام
الطائفيه هم الذين نفذوا اكبر حرب اباده
طائفيه في التاريخ الحديث هم الذين قتلوا
مليون سني لمجرد انهم سنه هؤلاء الذين
قتلوا مليون سني يتهموننا نحن اهل جبل
العرب باننا طائفيون لمجرد رفع رايه رايه
الدروز الرايه التي يرفعها المتظاهرون هذه
يعني مشان الناس تعرف عفوا عفوا الرايه
التيي يرفعها المتظاهرون في السويداء طبعا
هي مش علم هي رايه هي الرايه التاريخيه
للموحدين ماهر ماهر حتى ليست رايه هي بيرق
بيرق بالمناسبه بالمناسبه حرام بس دقيقه
دقيقه وهذا السؤال يعني حرام حرام يعني
مجموعه او مدينه ترفع بيرق الخاص بيرق
ثقافي ثقافي بالدرجه الاولى طيب هؤلاء
الذين يعيرون وهذا نحن نتكلم فيه يعيرون
بس دقيقه هؤلاء الذين يعيرون المنتفضين
بالسويد انه يحملون رايه مين مين قال قال
حسن نصر الله وحزب الله اللي عنده الول
دويله داخل الدوله وعنده علم خاص فيه وعلى
يعني اذا عملنا مقارنه بين رايه السويداء
وعلم حزب الله على الاقل هؤلاء يحملون
رايه العروبه رايه العزه رايه الكرامه مش
حاملين علمهم ودايرين بالمنطقه يذبحوا
الناس على الهويه وطائفه كيف ترد اكثر من
ذلك بس اسمح لي في نقطه مهمه هذه الرايه
تجاوزت رمزيتها الدينيه انا بقول لك طبعا
هي رايه بالاصل رايه دينيه عمرها اكثر من
ال سنه ولكن عند بعد تاريخي لان الدروس
طوال 1000 سنه قاتلوا قاتلوا تحت ظلال هذه
الرايه هل تعلم الناس كثير ما بتعرف اهم
معارك الثوره السوريه الكبرى ضد الفرنسيين
خيضت تحت هذه الرايه معركه الكفر المزرعه
المسيفري سلطان الاطرش كان يخوض المعارك
تحت هذه الرايه اذهب الى المتحف الحربي
الفرنسي على النت منشوره صور المتحف
الحربي الفرنسي يعرض هذه الرايه في فرنسا
الجنرال ساراي استعرض رايات الدروس كغ نام
حرب بعد معركه المسيفري ليش لانه الثوار
الدروس كانوا يقاتلون في الثوره السوريه
الكبرى تحت هذه الرايه بمعنى ان هذه
الرايه تتجاوز ابعادها الدينيه انها اليوم
رايه تاريخيه عاطفيه ترتبط بالدفاع عن
الارض والوجود وليست مجرد رايه دينيه هذه
الرايه هي رايه سلطان الاطرش وسلطان حمل
هذه الرايه بيد ثم حمل العلم السوري باللد
الاخرى لذلك قال سماحه الشيخ حكمه الهجري
قال بان ان هذه الرايه هي التي ساهمت برفع
هذا العلم كيف ترد بس كمان ايضا نقطه حول
تفضل تفضل باختصار نعم لا بدي احكي عن
مساله
الاداد اعطيني اعطيني ارد اول شيء استاذ
طيب دقيقه خلي خلي موضوع الاعداد اجعلوا
اجعلوا ما كيف ترد محمود الافندي تفضل
تفضل اول شيء لم اتهم بالطائف الامر الامر
اتهمت بعض الاشخاص الذي يرفعون فقط علامز
الدرزيه وتمنع العلام الاخرى الصراع كان
بين علم ما يسمى الثوره السوريه بين مالك
ابو الخير ومالك جراده اصبح معروفا وسرب
الحكومه الس سربت كل التسجيلات الصوتيه تم
يمنع الان اخراج فقط علم الدروز اذا انت
اذا انت ليس طائفي ليس تريد الانفصال
فتسمح لعلام الاخرى هذا اول شيء ثاني شيء
انا لم اتهم بالانفصال اتهم فقط فئه صغيره
التي تقود المظاهرات
والاحتجاجات تقاد من من الجوار من اسرائيل
من يقود هذه الجوار مالك جراده من
اسرائيل في ضابط اسرائيل مذهل العطش الان
يعطي الاوامر الى
الحرا يا محمود يا محمود بس ب اسالك محمود
محود مود التاريخ الايام بيننا بس بدي
اسالك هل تعلم هل تعلم اين هل تعلم بس
الايام بيننا هل تعلم اين جثه حافظ الاسد
الان ليست في القرداحه موجوده بمكان ثاني
والتاريخ بفرجيك وين موجوده جثه حافظ
الاسد ولك حاكم تلعبوا بال بعبع
الاسرائيلي وانتم تنامون في الحضن
الاسرائيلي
ليار جثه حا
اسدين اسمع اسم اسمعني شي اين على بطل
اسمعني ثواني
بسرب صدقني لو كانت نيه الحراك الحراك نيه
الحراك
نيه عقول اثنين على بطل م بطل ولكن نيه
الحراك لو كان نيه
الحراك لو كان نيه الحراك نيه سليمه لال
التحمت كل اهالي سويداء ل التحمت كل اهالي
سويداء اهالي سويداء لا تشارك في الحراك
يشارك فقط اعداد صغيره فقط يعني لو نرى لو
كانت الاحتجاجات لاصبح السيا مدني لقام كل
شعب السويده في الشوارع اين شعب السويده
ان اللي اراف الكاميرات فقط عباره عن مئات
الاشخاص يرفعون عالم واحد ويهدد ويهدد من
يرفع علام اخرى هذا امر مهم جدا اهم شيء
المنظمين ثاني شيء سلطه
الاحتجاجات الشعارات تفضل الاحجا ي لك
الشعب يريد اسقاط النظام ومعه ماسك الورقه
مكتوب عليها يد تطبيق القرار الامي 2 ا خ
ا طب الا يقرا اول شيء شو كتب 2 ا خ ا ما
فيه اسقاط النظام وهو يطالب باسقاط النظام
هذا الدليل انه هناك ايادي خارجيه تلعب
بهذه الفئه من الع العالم فقط الان تدعي
الى مناسف تدعي الى كل شيء يعني بس تاعوا
وتاع اللي حصل يوم الجمعه انه ما حدا اجا
شوف صور اللي حصل يوم الجمعه الماضي من
حوالي ثلاث ايام حتى قلت لك
ح فقط عندما تحول الساحه عندما تحول
الساحه تبكه ما في اعداد ما في لا تكبر
الموضوع ليس هناك انتفاضه لو كان في
انتفاضه كما تقال لما ذهب الرئيس الاسد
الى الصين الانسان بيكون عنده انتفاضه
داخل بلده كان كان ولو كان في انتفاضه
حقيقيه لا ارتدت على الشعب السوري ولكن
الشعب السوري يرى ما يحصل في السويداء
ارقام قليله لذلك لم تذهب اختنقت هذه
الاحتجاجات ضمن مدينه ضمن اشخاص معينين لم
يدعمها شعب السويدا ولا انسان من الشعب
السوري دعم هذه الاحتجاجات لذلك ولدت ميته
ل تستط
شدين جميل وصلت الفكره ماهر شرف الدين
ولدت ميته بدك ترد الاعداد الاعداد بس
دقيقه خليني اسالك يا اخي مثل ما سالته
الاعداد قليله جدا ولا تظهر ان هناك
انتفاضه ماشي هناك ايادي خارجيه تحركها
هناك الشعب السوري غير يعني مبالي بالمره
اذا صح التعبير بهذه الانتفاضه ولم يدعمها
اه وباك برر دليل على ذلك انه عندما كان
هناك يعني انتفاضه او بما تسميها انت
انتفاضه في السويداء سياده
الرئيس المفدى كان في الصين ذهب الى الصين
ما بعرف شو بده يبيع هذه المره شو
رايك اول شيء من شان الاعداد في احدى
الجمع وصل عدد المتظاهرين في ساحه الكرامه
الى حوالي 10000 متظاهر فينا نجيب
الفيديوهات لتلك الجمعه ونحولها لصور
وتحسب حساب تقريبي للاعداد احدى الجمع وصل
العدد ل 10 الا هذا غير المظاهرات في
ساحات القرى والبلدات يعني الناس عم بترك
ركز على ساحه الكرامه لانه هي الساحه
الاكبر لكن هناك اكثر من 130 قريه وبلده
في السويداء وهناك مظاهرات في كل ساحات
تلك البلدات والقرى الناس مش كل الناس
فيهم يوصلوا الى ساحه الكرامه الناس ما
معها تدفع ايجار طريق يعني لما يقدر
متظاهر واحد يوصل الى ساحه الكرامه في
مقابله 50 متظاهر مش قادرين يوصلوا لا في
بنزين لا في مصاري حتى ما في باصات النظام
مهدد اصحاب الباصات بقطع مخصصات الوقود عن
كل سائق باص يشارك في نقل المتظاهرين لذلك
الناس عم تضطر تركب بالسيارات الصغيره
بالسيارات الخاصه تبعها وهذا تنقل مكلف
جدا في ظل الكارثه المعيشيه لو في وسائل
نقل انا باكد لك انه ساحه الكرامه رح
يحتشد فيها 200,000 انسان لو كانت بتوزع
بخصوص مساله حساب الاعداد بالمظاهرات
والنسبه والتناسب يا اخي لما مصر عملت
مظاهره سموها مليونيه اسقطت الرئيس بهذه
المظاهره مع انه عدد سكان مصر اكثر من 100
مليون يعني ما فيك تجي تقول هذول مليون من
اصل 100 مليون ما فيك تقول هذول
بالك بس خليني اقوللك يا ماهر انت نسان
انت نسيان انك يا ماهر بجمهوريه
99.99% انت بتعرف يعني سياده الرئيس اذا
ما جاب
99.99% وصوتوا له الاموات كمان ما ب ما
بتكون عنده شعبيه ولا بكون عنده اصلا
جماهيريه فهذه عقليتهم يعني لازم 99.99
اذا واحد غاب اذا واحد غاب خلص ما
بيعترفوا عليك نعم حتى بال 99 انا عم
بعطيك اياها بشكل منطقي يعني انت بمظاهره
مصر مليون من اصل 100 مليون ما فيك تيجي
تقول هذول 1% لانه هال المليون بيعبروا عن
ال 100 مليون اللي قاعدين بالبيوت يعني
بيجي هلا جماعه النظام بقولوا لك والله
عدد المتظاهرين في السويداء ما بيطلع 1%
من سكان السويداء مش هيك بتنحب الامور
بالمظاهرات لانه مقابل كل متظاهر استطاع
الوصول الى ساحه الكرامه هناك 50 متظاهر
لم يستطع الوصول شغله ثانيه بخصوص الزياره
ل للصين يعني تصور انه الثوره بالسويد
قائمه تتصدر نشرات الاخبار بينما بشار
الاسد يجري مقابله على التلفزيون الصيني
لا ياتي فيها على ذكر السويداء يعني عم
يشترط على التلفزيون الصيني انه ما يسالوا
عن السويده وبالمناسبه هل تعلم هل تعلم
لحظه هل تعلم ما هي اهم نتيجه لزياره
الصين يا دكتور فيصل النتيجه الاهم لزياره
الصين ليست سياسيه بل اكثر من 100 شنطه من
اكسسوارات الموبايلات اسماء الاسد جلبت
معها في الطائره اكثر من 100 شنطه محال
محمله باكسسوارات الموبايلات لشركتها
امتين الصينيين تر ليك دكتور دكتور بدون
خلينا خلينا بال الموضوع ماهر ماهر خلينا
بالموضوع بد خلنا بالوضوع واحد يهرب بس
كلمه بس كلمه بس كلمه بس كلمه الصينيين ما
عندها شركه امتيل يا اخي هي
هي مهتمين بالتلفونات والصينيين ترى عملوا
حركه عجبتني مين كان باستقباله لبشار
الاسد بالمطار يا دكتور مين كان وزير
التجاره الصيني يعني تصور بعثوا له وزير
التجاره ليستقبله انه الصينيين من الاخر
عار عينه عارفينه جاي يتاجر شو عندك لتبيع
شو حملنا بهال الشنطه قال لهم والله ما ظل
عندي شي لبيعه بعت كل شيء لروسيا وايران
قال لهم انا مش جاي بياع انا جاي شره جاي
انا وزوجتي نشتري
موبايلات خلنا بالوضوع ما ماهر ماهر لم
تجب لم تجب على موضوع انه لم يتحرك الشعب
السوري يعني انت تطبل وتزمر لكن اقول لك
الرجل الشعب السوري لم يتحرك فلماذا انت
متفائ لا الشعب السوري لا لا الشعب السوري
طلع بمظاهرات طبعا ليست بالمستوى المتوقع
دكتور الشعب السوري 12 سلم فلح يعني بقيه
المحافظات فلحت دمرت بالبراميل الشعب
السوري ثلاث ارباعه مهجر ثلاث ارباعه نازح
الشعب السوري يعني حقيقه انا بقولوا لي
طلاع ناشد السوريين ليظهروا والله ما لي
عين اطلع نشدهن لانه دفعوا ما عليهم واكثر
طبعا هذا خطا كمان تكتيكي واستراتيجي
دائما انه بتتظاهر محافظه بتنام بقيه
المحافظات شو ما نسوي ايضا لا تنسى ضغوط
الدول الجاره يعني انا بقول لك في احدى
المحافظات انا متاكد وصلني معلومات انه
احدى الدول الاقليميه تضغط على وجهاء تلك
المحافظه من اجل عدم التظاهر بحجه ان هذا
الحراك حراك انفصالي يعني بدهم يساعدوه
لبشار باي طريقه هذا هو السبب طيب محمود
الافندي نقطه مر عليها ماهر سريعا الان
البعض يتساءل على ضوء انتفاضه السويداء
بالمناسبه محمود الافندي انت لم نشاهد على
شاشات التلفزيون ان اهالي السويداء الذين
شردهم نظام الاسد وهم بمئات الالاف
بالخليج فقط هناك م 200 الف شاب من
السويداء في فنزويلا وامريكا عدد الدروز
اكثر من عددهم في في في السويداء وفي
سوريا اه لم تشاهد مظاهراتهم في فنزويلا
وفي استراليا وفي كندا وفي كل بقاع العالم
انت تعلم انت تعلم ماذا ماذا فعل هذا
النظام الاقليات رفع شعار حمايه الاقليات
من الذي هجر كل الاقليات من سوريا الدروز
من هجرهم هل تعلم المسيحيون في سوريا
المسيحيون لم يبقى منهم الا قله قليله جدا
النسبه الاكبر من المسيحيين الذين تهجروا
من سوريا هجرهم النظام السوري نظام حافظ
الاسد وهذا بشهاده المسيحيين انفسهم واسال
جورج كدر الباحث السوري المعروف اذا الان
بعد السويداء سقطت كل كل اوراق التوت عن
عورات النظام ماذا سيفعل برايك ماذا سيفعل
لم يبقى لديه اي ورقه يلعبها كيف
ترد اول شيء يعني بالنسبه للعدد خليني
اعقب على العدد لو كان كما يقول انه 10000
كان معتصم في ساحه الكرامه يعني العالم
اقتنت وصار عفيسي يعني ساحه الكرمه كما
قلت
لكك 100 في نه في
نقطه مش را نناقش 99
خلص مين استقبل مين استقبل الرئيس الاسد
استقبل الرئيس الاسد استقبل بالصين ثواني
خلب على كلمه مهمه حذ ما رئيس الاسد
استقبل بالصين بالبروتوكول رقم واحد الصين
كما روسيا لا تخرج رؤساء الى المطار ولكن
استقبل بالبروتوكول رقم واحد يعني كما
استقبل الرئيس الجزائري كما استقبل الرئيس
الص الروسي نفس الاستقبال ونفس
الشخصان مع الرس الرو محمود بس خلي على
النقطه هذ
دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه محمود محمود محمود هذه
نقطه يجب ان لا تمر وذكرها ماهر ما فائده
ان يستضيفك الرئس
بين
يفون حزبك ورموك وشعارك وتماثيل وتماثيل
وصورك وصور وتماثيل الاقدمين كلياتهم ما
فائده يعني اين يستقبلون الرئيس الصين
استقبلكم على الغداء السوريون يستقبلون
تماثيل ورموز تحت اقدامهم ما فائده ان
تاكل البط المشوي وستير فراي في الصين يا
سيدي النظام استقبل في الصين لكن كان
السوريون يدوسون على كل على كل رموزه داخل
سوريا لك واحد معقول فيك عندك ثوره رايح
تاكل ستير فراي بالصين انت او رايح تاكل
بط
مشوي سي يس اول شيء ليس ليس هناك ثوره في
سوريا لانه كما قلت لك لا عددا ولا شعارات
ليس موجود اول شيء ثاني شيء الوضع اللي
حصل بالسودا لا يلقي بانتفاضه حتى الان
يعني حتى الان ليس هناك حشد وليس
هناك ارجع لي على سؤالي ارجع على سؤالي
تقول انا انا قلت سعود ارجع على سؤالك انا
ارجع لك سؤالك ارجع على سؤالك من يخرب
بسوريا هي عمليات تقوم فيها بعض الاشخاص
في السويداء يقومون بحركات استفزازيه بكسر
التماثيل باغلاق مقر حزب البعث حتى يبدا
ان الحكومه السوريه بالعنف هم يريدون
العنف للاستقلال يريدون ان يطلق اول طلقه
حتى تشعل الدم ويبدا النزاع اذا بدا
النزاع لا احد يهدي هذا النزاع لذلك يريد
ال اللي حرك السويداء الان يريدون من
الحكومه السوريه ان تبدا في اطلاق النار
وقمع المتظاهرين في هذه المنطقه لذلك
يقومون بهذه العمليه السياسيه ولكن لاحظ
الحكومه السوريه وحكمتها حتى الان لم
تعتقل اي انسان ولم تتدخل لماذا هذه
الحكمه هي استوعبت لذلك في بدايه اللقاء
قلت لك ان الحكومه السوريه سبقت
الاحتجاجات الحكومه السوريه كل يوم تسرب
المكالمات الهاتفيه اللي كلموها المحتجين
بين بعضهم واللي عم با اسسوا المظاهرات عم
با اسسوا الاحتجاجات بخيانتهم يعني نشرت
على التلفزيون السوري وتلفزيونات العالم
عده مكالمات
هاتفيه محمود الوقت الوقت يداهمنا قبل ان
اذهب بسؤالك قبل ان ذب بس دقيقه قبل ان
اذهب الى ماهر بسؤالك بس مشان نوزع الوقت
يا سيدي لماذا تبدو انت لماذا تبدو ابواق
الشبيحه ملكيه اكثرا من الملك بشار الاسد
بعظمه لسانه في مقابلته مع التلفزيون
الصيني قال قال نحن في الحضيض نحن محاصرون
نحن جائعون نحن نموت نحن كذا واعترف الرجل
بعظمه لسانه بانه يعني بانه في تحت التحت
فبت جي انت بتطلع لي وبتفرد لي عضلات
وبتفرد لي كذا اذا الزلمه عارف حاله انه
تحت تحته مدعوس وملعون ابو اللي جابهم
فانت بتطلع بتدافع وبتقول لي الدوله
والدوله دوله ايه ونيره ايه يا رجل السؤال
المطروح يا محمود يا محمود البعض يقول لك
النظام السوري يشعر يشعر بغبط وبفرح كبير
عندما يسمونه النظام السوري ليس هناك نظام
لم يعد هناك نظام اصلا ما في نظام لا دوله
ولا نظام هناك عباره عن مافيات مافيات
وعصابات مافيات وعصابات عصابات الكبتاجون
عصابات النفط عصابات التشريد عصابات
التعفيش عصابات التخريب الزراعي عصابات
البلد عباره عن عصابات عصابات ما قعد في
نظام اصلا كيف
ترد
طبعا سوريا الان في وضع محاصره هي محاصره
محتل اراضيها من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه محتله الموارد النفطيه والموارد
الطاقه يلي بتشكل موارد الطبيعيه بتشكل
حوالي 75% من الاراضي السوريه الليي عم
بتقول انه النظام باع الى اوروبا مع ان
الولايات المتحده تحتلها من المفروض ان
يكون
الحراك ل الحراك لو الحراك لو كان شريفا
لطالب الولايات لك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تسيطر على 75% من المرا
الطبيعيه السوريه يا اخي ان كان الزراعيه
ان كان الطاقه علىك رئه سوريه الشمال
المناطق زراعيه لو كان لو كان الحراك لو
كان الحراك شريفا انا ما سمعت ثواني ثواني
ثواني بسو لو كان الحراك شريفا لو كان
حراك شريفا خليه حراك شريفا لخرج
المتظاهرين وطالبوا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالخ سوريه ل اسمع هذ المطالب
فقط ماي ماشي محمود محمود محمود محمود انا
معك تماما بس لماذا تطلب من حراك سلمي لا
يحمل سكين ان يهجم على امريكا ليش ما
بيهجم عليه جيش الباص تبعك لماذا يذهب
ويحرر ليش لاحق العشائر في دير الزور
ولاحق اهل سويده يحرروا له يحرروا له شرق
الفرات ليش وين عضلاته يحتفظ بكل شيء الى
الى شو اسمه في الزمان والمكان المناسبين
كل يوم بينداس كل يوم بينداس الف مره من
اسرائيل ومن كذا وجاي تطلب لي اهل سويده
يروحوا يح
حيب ماه شرف
الدينين شرف الدين ماه شرف الدين ما يحدث
في السويداء ماهر شرفدين
ماشي ماهر شرف الدين ما يحدث في السويداء
حركات
استفزازيه يعني هل انت تقبل بما يفعله اهل
السويداء بافرع
الحزب اقسام
الدوله اول شيء افرع الحزب ليست اقسام
للدوله هو عصاب هذا الحزب تحول الى عصابه
تحتل وتستثمر وتستخدم على وجه غير مشروع
لمرفقات الدوله ها اولا الشغله الثانيه
اللي مارس العنف هو هذا النظام لما اطلق
النار من خلال فرع حزب البعث وجرح ثلاثه
اشخاص ولو ردوا لو كانوا اهل السويداء غير
سلميين كانوا اقتلعوا هذا الحزب والله
بنصف ساعه ولكن الناس يعني الناس ملتزمه
بالسلميه وسماحه الشيخ حكمه الهجري قال
اتركوا ابقوا الطلقه في بيت النار والطلقه
الاولى لن تب لن تخرج منا نحن لن نطلق اي
طلقه الا دفاعا عن النفس ولكن يا دكتور من
نكد الدنيا على الحر ان يرى تجار
الكبتاجون يحاضرون عليه بالوطنيه اليوم
العالم كله ينظر الى نظام بشار الاسد
كعصابة ظام الا وبتكون القضيه الاولى اللي
بطرحها معه هي قضيه الكبتاجون ما في حدا
من خارج سوريا بيحكي مع بشار الا بيبدا
حديثه معه عن قصه الكبتاجون ما خلوا شيء
ما حشوه كبتاجون حشوا الفواكه حشوا الخضره
حشوا علب الحليب لذلك انا سميته لبشار شيخ
المحشي الثابت الوحيد دكتور اليوم بما يخص
الانتفاضه الثابت الوحيد هو ان الناس في
السويداء حسموا خيارهم وطوا صفحه الاسد
بشكل كامل ولكن لا احد يستطيع ان يخمن
الذي
ر كيف كيف اغلق صح زمه كيف يا ماهر كيف يا
ماهر بو صفحه الاسد اولا لم يبقى رمز
للنظام موجود في سويداء لم يبقى لا تمثال
لا صوره لا فرع لحزب البعث ثانيا اهل
السويداء لن نعم نعم النظام الان يحاول كل
جهد اخماد هذه
المرجع
تفضل كمل كمل عفوا عفوا عفوا يا محمود
والله ما قطعتك والله انا حربتي مش قصيره
بقاطع يعني النظام اليوم يحاول كل جهده
اخماد هذه المظاهرات من خلال تفخيخها من
الداخل يعني عم حااول يشق الصف اول شيء
حاول شق الصف من خلال العائلات وفشل ثم
حاول يشق الصف من خلال البوابه الدينيه
وفشل يعني يجوا عملوا لنا هيئه دينيه
مسخره عرفت كيف جابوا واحد كان كان عنصر
بال مخابرات ولبسوه زي ديني وقالوا هذهه
هيئه دينيه وما حدا اعترف فيها ولن ينجح
هذا النظام بشق الصف لانه لا يوجد تكافؤ
اغلب اهل الجبل مع الشيخ الهجري ومع ما
يمثله الشيخ
الهجري عفوا النظام اليوم في ورطه كبرى
فكما سبق ان قلت السويداء
ليست منطقه سنيه ليقوم بقصفها بالبراميل
وليست منطقه علويه ليقوم بضبطها لذلك ليس
لديه سوى الفتن والالعاب الامنيه وبعض
المهرجين المستجلبة
كل ثورات سوريا تبدا بالسويداء وتنتهي بال
تبدا بجبل العرب وتنتهي بجبل العرب وانت
بتعرف لولا جبل العرب ما كان في شيء اسمه
سوريا ما كان في شيء اسمه سوريا ونحن ما
عم نطب لها بس هذا هو للتاريخ فلهذا لا
نذهب بعيدا الان الان هل تستطيع ان تنكر
محمود الافندي ان
شخصيه الشيخ بو سلمان حكمه الهجري اصبح
شخصيه وطنيه رمزا وطنيا س
بامتياز من شمال سوريا الى جنوب سوريا ومن
شرق سوريا الى غرب سوريا الكل الان اذهب
الى حلب بلدك اذهب الى حمص اذهب الى دمشق
الكل اعين الجميع الان ترنو الى هذا الرمز
الوطني العظيم الذي خرج من السويداء لاول
مره انتفاضه تخلق زعامه وقياده وطنيه
زعامه وقياده وطنيه ولا تستطيع ان تنكر
ذلك عدد الاتصالات التي تلقاها بو سلمان
اه اكبر من عدد خلال اسبوعين اكبر من عدد
الاتصالات التي تلقاها بشار الاسد على مدى
12 عاما انت بتعرف مين كان يزوره واحد
بواب واحد نائب نائب نائب وزير نائب نائب
نائب مدير تربيه حنكوش الشماليه وما بعرف
شو كيف
ترد اول الشيء يعني دائما انتفاضه لم يكن
هناك انتفاضه في السويداء لذلك لم تنتقل
الى مدن اخرى تكلم هذا الكلام ثاني شيء
النظام او الحكومه تسقط في العاصمه ولا
تسقط في مدينه بعيده عن العاصمه اول شيء ث
ثاني شيء اهم شيء العاصمه السوريه لم
تنتفض لاهل السويداء لانه يعلمون ما هو
البديل الان البديل عن كل هذه المظاهرات
وهذه الشعارات هو الدمار وهو الارهاب يعني
تعلمنا جي الدمار اللي عمله النظام هذا ما
له قيمه الدمار اللي عمله النظام هذا ما
له قيمه ا
الحكومه السوريه ضرب لما الانسان شيل سلاح
طب ليش الدمار ليش الدمار مو العالم شالت
سلاح بوجه الحكومه السوريه طب انت اي دوله
في العالم والعالم بتشيل سلاح بتيجي اي
حكومه بتضربه هذا شيء طبيعي يعني نحن
نتكلم عن شيء طبيعي لذلك يلي عم يحصل الان
في السوداء بالسوداء ليس اكثر من زبعه
بفنجان لن تتطور هذه المظاهره لن تتطور
لتصبح انتفاضه لانه الشعارات غير لائقه
باهل السويداء هذا امر مهم جدا تذكرني
بالشيخ انا نسيت اس تقوللي عليه ما حدا
بسوريا بيعرفه هو مع فقط عن طريق وسائل
الاعلام عم
تنور تكلم من تكلم معه سؤال تكلم تكلم
معق
يا
اخي ابرايم هلك ولا اي شخصيه ونيه ر يا
ماهر ماهر ماهر ماهر اي شخصيه وطنيه انت
اخترعت ديار اعلامي اكر من دقيقه انت
تخترع اشخاص تعطوهم البطوله يعني محمود
ماهر كيف ترد عليه بدون مقاطعه كيف ترد
على كلام اخي عم اقول انه الشيخ الهجري ما
بمثله بالتاكيد الشيخ الهجري ما بيمثله
الشيخ الهجري يمثل احرار البلاد اليوم
الشيخ الهجري صار شخصيه وطنيه يرفع اسمه
من الحسكه الى ادلب الى درعا في كل مكان
واليوم مضافه الشيخ الهجري صارت اهم من
قصر المهاجرين وكما قلنا الاتصالات
الدوليه التي اجريت مع الشيخ الهجري بشهر
واحد اكثر من اتصالات الدوليه التي اجرت
مع بشار الاسد طوال 12 سنه يعني بشار
الاسد اراد ان يعزل السويداء عن العالم
فقامت السويداء بعزل عن عالم زادت من
عزلته اكثر فاكثر هلا هو عم يحكي في نقاط
دكتور ما رح مرق له اياه عم ققول انه هنا
عم يكشفوا مخططات الانتفاضه من خلال
تسريبات غرف واتساب يا اخي يا غرف واتساب
عامه فيها 600 700 واحد يعني مش بطوله اي
واحد في يفوت على هذه الغرفه شغله ثانيه
عم اقول 22
54 في خلا انه انه انه الناس عفوا انه
الناس مش عارفه شو عم تقول لا يا اخي 22
54 هو الاليه الوحيده الممكنه لتفكيك هذا
النظام الناس عارفه لما عم تطرح 22 54
عارفين شو عم يطرحوا لانه بده يصلوا الى
تفكيكها للنظام مرحله انتقاليه يعني مرحله
انتقاليه
سلطه انتقاليه كامله الصلاحيات بشار بيقعد
على جنب 18 شهر بصير بعديه انتخابات
باشراف الامم المتحده الناس لما عم تطالب
22 54 عارفين بشو عم يطالبوا شغله اخرى عم
اقول شيء طبيعي شيء طبيعي تدمير البلاد
يعني تخيل انه قال بشار عم يدافع عن عن
نفسه فشيء طبيعي انه يدمر بلد يعني حتى
نحن بتعرف نحن ال سويدا عننا قضيه مع
الشيشكلي ولكن الشيشكلي يا اخي لما شاف
الجيش بده ينق ولما
سؤال لما
راحب من
البلاد بس يا جماعه بس دقيقه بس يا
جماعه ماهر ماهر ماهر انتهى الوقت
بدقيقه السؤال لمحمود محمود محمود الافندي
بجمله واحده سوريا الى اين سوريا الى اين
بعد انتفاضه جبل العرب الاشم بجمله واحده
بس بجمله واحده سوريا الى التقدم بانه ليس
هناك انتفاضه هناك فقط زوبعه في فنجان
الشعب السويده شعب وطني وعظيم ولا يريد
الطائفيه وهو
وطني مين عم بيحكي عن الطائفيه الحكم
الطائفي اللي بيحكمنا من 50 سنه بالطائف
ماشي ماشي ماهر شرف الدين ماهر شرف الدين
باختصار ماه شرف الدين ماهر شرفدين عفوا
كلمه اخيره بس كلمه اخيره سوريا الى اين
نعم عم بقول انه ما يحدث في سوريا
والسويداء وزوبع في فنجان يا ريت يجيب لي
هالفنجان انا بعرف بصر بلكي بدي ابصر له
فيه بس كلمه يا دكتور انت قلت دائما كل
الثورات تبدا من جبل عرب الثورات تبدا من
جنوب سوريا درعا هي بدات الثوره والسويداء
ستنه باذن الله ستنه بتحقيق حلم الشعب
السوري بزوال هذه الطغمه الحاكمه من
اللصوص وتجار الكبتاجون شكرا جزيلا
مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى لنا ان نشكر ضينا
من موسكو محمود الافندي ومن امريكا ماهر
شرف
الدين نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين ها هو فيصل القاسم يحييكم من
الدوحه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء